clic clic waouh tu fais ip à bien le
clic merci abonne toi
salut romain ça va ça va by michael nick
m ah d'accord
donc tu es là maintenant alors je vais
parler d'un truc si dans une discussion
je glisse le mot méninges et une
méningite à méningocoque vous allez
hocher la tête ce soir oui oui ça va je
connais et on va passer à autre chose
maintenant si je m'interromps et que je
vous demande mais tu sais vraiment ce
que c'est la méningite tu sait vraiment
ce que ça une méningite
il va peut-être y avoir un petit blanc
je vais me retrouver à vous expliquer
deux ou trois trucs et à la fin vous
allez me dire un truc genre ah ben je
sais pas que c'était ça où on fait la
fête
bon c'est bon ça va là on a compris le
concept en fait vous êtes lourd
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà maintenant qu'on est entre nous
maintenant qu'on est entre nous on va
pouvoir parler un peu tranquillement de
cette maladie dont vous avez sûrement
déjà entendu parler mais je suis à peu
près sûr qu'il ya deux ou trois trucs
que vous ignorez à son sujet la
méningite
du coup rapport à l'intro déjà avant
d'aller plus loin une méningite
c'est quoi une méningite mais vous
l'avez deviné si vous êtes un peu fidèle
à cette chaîne ou si vous êtes hyper
balèze en langue morte et en étymologie
c'est une inflammation des méninges
ah oui les ménages les ménages le mot
vous dit sûrement quelque chose parce
que vous l'avez déjà entendues soit dans
des expressions un peu à l'ancienne soit
dans des titres de série télé mais vous
savez peut-être parce que c'est andrey
les méninges c'est un peu la cellophane
de notre système nerveux central puisque
c'est une membrane qui enveloppe et qui
protège notre moelle épinière et notre
encéphale c'est à dire notre cerveau
mais aussi le tronc cérébral et le
cervelet non non le cervelet voilà
sauf que là de la cellophane on en met
trois couches parce que on parle quand
même de notre cerveau et de notre moelle
épinière pas d'une tranche de foie de
veau ces trois couches c'est la primaire
est la plus profonde
laraque no id est la dure mère qui est
le plus à l'extérieur
alors comment on fait notre compte pour
nous retrouver avec les méninges
enflammé et bien le plus souvent c'est à
cause d'une infection vous savez comment
ça marche maintenant l'inflammation
c'est un moyen de défense de notre
organisme contre tout un tas de
problèmes dont les infections donc c'est
pour notre bien mais ça fait quand même
du mal et là précisément globalement
l'inflammation des ménages c'est une
réaction à une infection
parce qu'à l'intérieur des ménages entre
la primaire et laraque noïd ya un
liquide qui circulent le liquide
cérébro-spinal qu'on appelait avant le
liquide céphalo rachidien et qui a
plusieurs rôles de protection et
d'élimination des déchets on en a cent à
cent cinquante centimètres cubes ça fait
à peu près 3
schott s'est pas beaucoup mais c'est par
là que l'infection arrive dans l'absolu
une infection ça peut être causée par
plein de trucs un virus ou une bactérie
un champignon alors avoir un champignon
dans le cerveau ça existe ça s'appelle
une méningite fongiques
c'est dangereux mais c'est rare la
méningite virale c'est à dire celle qui
est causée par un virus
mais bon par les temps qui courent
j'imagine que vous connaissez bien le
terme maintenant c'est la plus fréquente
mais elle est plutôt bénigne dans la
mesure où la plupart du temps on s'en
remet spontanément et sans séquelles en
quelques jours mais il reste les
bactéries et là c'est pas la même
limonade
là aussi c'est fréquent parce que comme
vous savez des bactéries on en a plein
sur nous et comme d'hab
tant qu'ils restent à leur place pas de
soucis mais si elle arrive à se faufiler
jusqu'au liquide cérébro-spinal et là on
parle pas de bactéries tropicale
incroyable on parle de déchets richa
colis ont des bactéries fécales dont on
a déjà parlé ici de streptocoques de
pneumocoques et de neisseria
meningitidis ce c'est-à-dire de
méningocoque sur lequel on va s'attarder
un petit peu parce que c'est la cause
principale de méningite aiguë et parce
que les méningites à méningocoques en
plus de risquer de se propager par
épidémies et la sai dont je crois que ça
va on a donné elles ont un certain
nombre de caractéristiques qui les
rendent très peu sympathique et oui
c'est un euphémisme et parce que ça
touche environ 500 mille personnes par
an dans le monde donc ça reste rare mais
ça évolue tellement vite qu'il vaut
mieux savoir ce que c'est pour savoir
quoi faire
l'un des premiers problèmes avec les
méningites en général et les méningites
à méningocoques en particulier c'est que
la plupart du temps ça arrive à des
personnes en bonne santé qui n'ont pas
de souci particulier
donc on s'y attend pas ensuite mais on
va reparler après les signes sont pas
toujours très claires donc on se méfie
pas et puis surtout une méningite à
méningocoque ça peut être fatal
en quelques heures ou laisser des
séquelles qui peuvent être handicapante
là on parle d'un taux de mortalité de 10
% c'est-à-dire une personne sur dix est
parmi les neuf autres les séquelles ça
peut être des amputations membres des
paralysies des retards mentaux des
troubles de la vue et de l'audition des
problèmes au niveau des reins etc
alors elle que je vous connais là en ce
moment même vous commencez à voir
et à sentir la transpi devra peut-être
même un ou deux qui saigne du nez calmez
vous l'idée comme d'hab c'est pas de
vous faire flipper c'est de vous donner
des infos pour que vous sachiez quoi
faire en cas de besoin c'est tout alors
déjà faut savoir que quand on parle de
méningite à méningocoque les personnes
les plus vulnérables c'est les
nourrissons les enfants de moins de cinq
ans les adolescents et les personnes
immunodéprimées
c'est à dire les personnes qui ont un
système immunitaire moins efficace soit
à cause d'une maladie soit à cause d'un
médicament
ok mais alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
bon déjà il ya des vaccins contre
plusieurs bactéries qui peuvent être
responsables de mélanger il y en a qui
sont obligatoires comme le vaccin contre
l'haemophilus influenzae de type b
le pneumocoque ou le méningocoque c et
il y en a qui sont recommandées dans
certaines situations à risque ensuite
petit conseil quand j'étais infirmier en
réanimation
je me suis occupé d'un patient qui avait
une méningite et qui n'était pas au top
vous vous en doutez un vu qu'il était en
réanimation et bien le point de départ
de sa méningite c'était une otite pas
soigné donc de manière globale le
meilleur conseil que je puisse vous
donner c'est quand vous sentez qu'il ya
quelque chose qui va pas même si à la
base ça a l'air d'être à grand chose
laissez pas traîner ça c'est la règle
générale mais on va préciser un peu dans
le cas qui nous intéresse
l'autre problème avec la méningite comme
je voulais dire un peu plus tôt c'est
que les symptômes bas dans un premier
temps c'est plus ou moins ceux de la
grille dans les premières heures on a de
la fièvre
on a mal à la gorge le nez qui coule on
est un peu patraque
on est un peu irritable on n'a pas très
fin on peut avoir des nausées
autant vous dire qu'on pense pas direct
à la méningite donc on s'inquiète pas
plus que ça les symptômes qui font
vraiment penser à une méningite
il apparaît souvent que dans un deuxième
temps mais assez vite un genre dont les
12 15 heures après les premiers donc ça
c'est déjà quelque chose qui doit vous
mettre la puce à l'oreille
ces signes ceux qui sont beaucoup plus
spécifique c'est quoi d'abord on ne
supporte pas la lumière comme quand vous
avez une migraine ou la gueule de bois
ensuite ce qu'on appelle le syndrome
méningé c'est à dire un gros mal de
crâne et la nuque raide et on peut aussi
avoir des petits points violet rouge ça
paraît sur la peau et
les extrémités qui viennent froide donc
là encore plus ça doit vous pousser à
faire quelque chose sans attendre mais
le problème c'est que bien sûr tout le
monde a pas tous ces signes et si on
parle d'un nourrisson ou d'un petit
enfant c'est pas toujours facile de
savoir qui ressent exactement donc il
faut surveiller ces changements de
comportement par exemple à ce stade même
avec les symptômes plus spécifique qui
apparaissent le diagnostic il est
difficile à faire
et pourtant il faut pas traîner parce
que plus est pris tôt mieux ça soigne et
moins il ya de risque de complications
et séquelles
et si on fait rien ça peut s'aggraver
vite le malade ils risquent de devenir
de plus en plus conçu de perdre
connaissance voire de convulsé à cause
de la tante cérébrale et ça peut finir
par évoluer vers ce qu'on appelle un
choc septique
c'est à dire qu'en gros l'état du malade
se répercute sur son coeur et sur la
circulation
la tension chutent tous les organes
souffrent parce qu'ils sont plus irrigué
correctement et ça peut aller jusqu'au
décès c'est le genre de chose qui peut
arriver en 24 à 48 heures donc garder à
l'esprit que une méningite à
méningocoque c est une urgence dans la
mesure où il ya un risque vital en
quelques heures donc il faut vite
consulter
il ya des moyens de prévention les
vaccins dont on a déjà parlé mais aussi
la distanciation avec les malades
le port du masque en cas de contacts
rapprochés ou la prise d'antibiotiques
en préventive parlez-en avec votre
médecin
sachez aussi que si on suspecte une
méningite on peut prélever un peu de
liquide cérébro-spinal et l'analyser
pour voir s'il est infecté est là pour
le coup le diagnostic il est posé direct
encore faut-il faire l'examen donc avoir
consulté ça se soigne avec des
antibiotiques spécifiques et bien sûr
tous les traitements nécessaires en
fonction de l'état du malade à son
arrivée mais ça se soigne
dans tous les cas que ce soit en
prévention que ce soit si vous avez un
doute ou pour poser des questions pour
ça comme pour tout le reste la base c
n'attendez pas que ce soit trop tard
pour faire quelque chose et surtout
parlez-en à votre médecin voit la dtcc
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos non
pardon excusez moi
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres mettez vous bien et
surtout en février
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]